hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage here in los angeles california
I'm your host Mike McCarty here with
Nick margarita
hey everybody an executive producer on
see if thieves Joe neat yeah hello
everyone how was your show going so far
yeah amazing like we couldn't ask for
more honestly the boots been crazy busy
trailers gone down incredibly well you
know really giving people though look at
what you're gonna be doing in sea of
thieves yeah so daring Microsoft press
conference night you know they unveiled
Xbox one X and then of course they went
over to a few games including yours and
you showed off some new stuff and tell
us about what if you get lost as well
yeah yeah you're one of 42 but I get to
show off a lot we did yeah I think we
had the longest segment in the entire
show
yeah about I in a half minutes um but uh
yeah it was really I think last year we
definitely excited a lot of people with
the potential at sea of leaves but we
didn't show off too much right it was
the kind of the ship battles and
obviously drinking and musical
intruments the most important things for
pirates but this time round it was like
okay but what are we gonna do in the
game that was what we wanted to show so
very much showing that classic pirate
adventure of like all the things you'd
expect of a crew going out in search of
treasure classic riddle map you know and
it was really important that we made
that rhyme like when we first put it
into the game it was just kinda like a
bullet point list of clues and it just
felt like a shopping list sure I'm done
and that wasn't quite party enough so we
added the rhymes do it then we then
we've layered in a ton of different
things into the world like shipwrecks
that you can find emergently storms in
the world is a very big kind of tonal
peace adds danger to the world and adds
kind of danger to your adventures firing
yourself on cannons because it's awesome
and the best - the best like feature I
think we're gonna ever deliver to be
honest in terms of allowing players
creativity in how they're going to
approach every adventure
I can't wait to fire him yeah well
that's partly because when you climb in
your head sticks at the end and yeah
looking around us and so when when we
were first putting that into game like
players and people on the dev team well
I haven't seen it I haven't seen you
jump in so I can have a look and as soon
as I do you know yeah yeah exactly right
but yeah that's that's the kind of
behavior encourages yes always fun so a
question I do have after following the
game for you know since you started
showing it off um so the the flow of the
overall game right we've I think was
last year I played the like the death
match between two ships and everything
and then you showed off like kind of
treasure maps and what the coop is gonna
feel like and of course fighting these
skeleton enemies like the overall flow
of the game so say I go home for the day
I boot up the game I get into the game
and I'm going like play for a few hours
what is like the structure of the game
like going from that deathmatch or to
the treasure hunting or just exploring
yeah so what we focused on leading up to
e3 was really just fleshing out that
that emergent world that world where
every whenever you're on a quest or
you're going out to achieve something
like it x marks the spot or a riddle map
every adventure is going to be different
because of all the features that are in
the world like that they all play with
you in different ways like when you're
swimming to an island or there might be
sharks around like and if you find
yourself I have a cannon to the island
something you've got very long swim
packed right and so all of these things
how they play together but we really
wanted to show that off because that's I
think that's the magic and it's at the
core of our game whereas like that's
that every single time you play every
single venture it's going to be
different and so what the team is
working on now is really our first real
true progression system and that's
that's gonna it's going to be our first
version of that and we're probably going
to show up around game storm or
something and once we've got that in
place we've kind of got the game its
core and because we've got quests we've
got creatures in the world we've got the
ship like all of these things that are
integral to the adventure and then the
progression system is really going to be
rewarding players for how they choose to
behave in the world and the things they
choose to go after so you know whether
that's you want to go out and sink other
player ships whether you just want your
work or you want to steal treasure off
their ships or or you want to be the
kind of classic Explorer going around
with the treasure maps exploring islands
collecting stuff like all of these
things will be recognized by the game
they'll build into your reputation and
it's kind of your quest to become a
pirate Legend and so because this game
quite unique you know we've been in our
alpha phase since December where we've
been working with insiders we started
with a thousand and we're now up to
about 75,000 invited and with a like
over a hundred thousand still clamoring
on the door waiting to get in but we
like the way we're operating now it's
going to be the way we operate this game
moving forward which is that we're going
to be constantly growing and adding and
updating this kind of living and
breathing world and every time we put
new features you know we put new
question we're going to bring
progression with that
and so you know you're never going to
have just one goal that you get to and
you're done and then you're going what
do we do now what do we do now
so there's always whenever we bring new
ways to play there's always reasons to
return and reasons to come back and and
if you want to become that kind of that
full-on pirate legends you're going to
need to do all of these things and you
kind of need to maintain it as well in
our world and so when when you're
progressing through systems you're going
to be rewarded in a way that suits them
so if you're doing really bloodthirsty
stuff the coin rewards you're going to
get the kind of cosmetics you're going
to get from the from the characters in
the game for whether it's your clothes
or it's all the items that you carry
they're really going to suit that so if
you want to show up and be that
bloodthirsty kind of Blackbeard of the
Seas and see your thieves you'll be
rewarded in that way and you'll be able
to show up in that way but it's kind of
up to the players as to how how they do
that and how they choose to show up to
other place yeah that's a cooperative
game I think one of the big questions a
lot of people ask is how important is
communication between the crew members
of the ship yeah yeah very important and
I think it's actually like the most
important thing in the game I'll be
honest like like if you don't
communicate it's a real struggle to be a
successful group and so obviously at the
moment our primary method of
communication is voice and we believe
really strongly in that as a
communication tool it's a really strong
one but we know that some players either
don't want to talk or maybe they they
have you know in a bit like that an
ability issue in terms of talking or in
terms of listening and so they need a
different system to be able to
communicate to people and so we are
currently working on our nonverbal
communication system so we've got a team
back at rail working on this and this is
this will be a contextual system so if
you're on the wheel or if you're on the
Canon or up in the crow's nest you'll
get a series of commands that you can
issue which will then go out to other
players and just allow you to
communicate in all the key ways that you
need to in the game and works and really
interesting stuff we've learned in our
technical alpha which kind of helped
prioritize us bringing this forward is
when we saw crews full of players that
were all talking they definitely have
the longest sessions the kind of highest
fund ratings and basically that the best
experience but our expectation was kind
of a full-on crew with all talking would
be the best a crew with a mix of like
none talking to talking would be the
second best and then if they weren't
talking at all but we thought that would
be the worst but
wasn't the case what happened was
obviously the full-on voice one was the
best when no one was talking they also
had good session experiences they played
along and they had good phone rings but
when you put a mix of people together
who had different kind of goals and
different likes sure they split up
sooner and it makes sense right with
high but it wasn't what excited because
we thought well the voice is the best or
at least if they got song though some
people are talking so they'll get on but
the people without voice found a way to
communicate and found a way to to kind
of cooperate but it was really
interesting and it something we couldn't
have learnt without doing the Alpha and
but it did kind of lead us to go okay
look we know we need to prioritize the
nonverbal communication system it's like
we need people to be able to communicate
problem you said you're showing off more
of a progression system in Germany later
this year at Gamescom that's the plan
yeah yeah um can you talk at all about
the progression itself is it like
there's there an effort to give it like
an RPG flavor or RPG light kind of
aspects um it's it's more kind of
reputational on how you show up against
other players in the world and then that
leads you to all of the different kind
of cosmetic things that you can earn so
like it's not like you're going to get
better at using a Canon right sure like
canons we love that that is flat that
kind of skill level is flat so some
people are just good at it and some
people are better on the wheel some
people prefer being the Crowsnest but
throughout any session you play to your
thieves you kind of do it all because
you kind of have to and half the time
you'll be sailing along and you realize
there's no one in the wheel because
you've all been running around doing
something else and that's part of the
magic of this I think and we don't want
to have barriers to entry that someone
who's played for 70 hours can't play
with someone that's played or to new to
it right if you've been playing it and
I'm your friend and I come along and
you're you're way ahead of me and I
can't come in play with you that's a
real barrier and we don't want that so
it's kind of that's that's where our
thinking is around so last year you guys
showcased the combat and this year is
more so about teamwork and treasure
hunting
can you talk about the new riddle quests
versus just x marks the spot like most
classic pirate stories absolutely yeah
so we first put the x marks the spot
and really that was just our getting our
first quest into the game and getting a
real use for islands and it's really
it's a really like we purposely don't
have a mini-map in the game right we
don't have a hard telling you where to
go we don't have markers on there
because we want people to use this
skills that they have in real life right
and it's kind of funny
since gps's have been introduced into
the world right like if you use a GPS
going somewhere the same time by the
same way for like a year and then you
break GPS breaks you can't find the way
to work anymore right because you don't
look at the world you don't you don't
use those skills and it's kind of the
same I think in games where you just
have the mini-map there all the time
where I've played games I don't look at
the world and I don't and it's it's a
waste for me and so it's it's natural to
have a map kind of a you know top-down
and then you're looking around you and
going all right there so there's a big
look here and and it's to the north and
okay that makes sense now I'm here and
you're orientate in yourself and it
really just gives you a different way of
playing a different way of navigating
and we believe really strongly that
that's kind of a like it's the
experience that we want and and our
players are reacting really well too so
like we got that in with the x marks the
spot and then we moved on to riddles
because we really want it to for what we
wanted to give a different flavor a
different way to play and we also wanted
something that players who weren't
playing but were watching could
contribute to and so we've had like
because we've always believed in see if
thieves is a game that is going to be
kind of as fun to watch as it is to play
because of all the crazy stuff that can
happen and we haven't been inviting kind
of creators into the studio over the
last six nine months you know the people
that make videos and who are experts at
what they do and their audience and what
their audience wants which is different
to a kind of traditional games
developers understanding of an audience
what we know how to make a game that
players are going to enjoy but we're in
this kind of new world where people love
to share their stories via streaming by
YouTube so getting in video creators to
play our game and to give us feedback
led us to talking about riddles and we
always had it in the plan but the fact
that like if you're at home and there's
there's this riddle with all of these
clues in and they're like find the
highest point on this island or find the
statue that looks like this anybody can
help contribute to that you know in the
chat they can be going oh I think it's
up here I think is up there and like
that's what that's what we've learned
about viewers love to contribute and so
it was a really interesting thing for us
to put in so we can then we've been
testing some streams out here as well
for the first time at e3 which has been
super fun and you know doing some Coe
streams on mixer and doing some stuff in
from the show floor
and so like it it felt there was so like
that wasn't the only reason for putting
them in but it was definitely when we
compared it to all the other different
quest types we could we were looking at
like bounties or merchant quests and
things like this which will part of the
classic pirate tropes which were not
afraid to embrace with afraid of cliches
let's have fun yeah right yeah so but
but it kind of gave it a little nudge
upped it was like okay let's try
something let's test it and let's test
to see if it is watchable and shareable
I propose that we use a lot but what it
also does is it engages your brain in a
completely different way as a player on
the islands because now not only are you
kind of looking at landmarks around you
but you're you're you're just surveying
the environment in a completely
different way exploring and trying to
find things that that relate to a
slightly cryptic clue so you're using
your kind of eyes but you try use your
brain as to what would be like the the
drunk pirates great like what would that
be and so you're you know you're trying
to find a grave first of all and then
it's like okay that's all that this
one's got kind of loads of empty empty
and mugs scattered all over it maybe
it's that one yeah and it's like okay so
northeast from here six steps oh yeah
and that that moment of satisfaction
when you when you work that stuff out is
incredible and it and yeah just very
unique ways to play and very unique
goals to go after I think for the chests
I noticed on the show floor and also
during the Xbox showcase that it's not
just a classic pirate chest there are
also some very unique ones could you
tell us a little bit about yes what's
being shown right now at e3 yeah sure so
um there's there's there's there's
basically a range of chests
some of which go from the classic kind
of rare through to legendary through to
mythical and in terms of value but
they're also what we call curse chests
in the game and they're quite rare to
find and I've only seen one article I
think where someone found them and they
actually had two in a row and I don't
know what the odds are of that but I'm
basically so that they're basically
chests with cursed pirate Souls in one
of those is the chest of a thousand
grogs which is basically when you dig it
up it's got like this pirates face on it
smiling is happy he likes grog but when
you pick it up it basically makes you a
little inebriated and makes it a lot
harder to get back to the ship and
it's also kind of because it's full of
these pirate Souls
you actually sounds a little bit like a
pop when you're carrying it so you can
hear everyone having fun and everything
else and it's kind of it's one of those
things that will happen quite rarely and
but it adds a completely different twist
because now the way you're playing is
very different maybe you're going to
swap it around between people or but
you're going to want to get it onto your
ship as soon as and probably take it
back and stuff because it's something
that's different unless you know unless
you don't unless you're fine with just
wandering around being drunk all the
time and that the other one is it's the
chest of sorrow and so this is Gannicus
chest with with the soul of a pirate and
but they're very sad and so occasionally
they'll cry and the chest will weep
water will come out of it and so if
you're carrying on your boat that's
going to be a problem because your your
boat will start filling up with water
and so your choice there is to try and
bail out water from the ship or maybe to
jump over the side and hold it over
there until until it's stopped crying
and then you can bring it back on board
and kind of carry on but we and we're
going to be adding to the kind of curse
chess system as we move forward there's
loads of different ways we can take that
and I think the same applies to all
elements of our game in terms of whether
it's the creatures in the world on sea
on land or the quest system the
progression system we're always going to
be growing all of those threads as we
move forward it's not one part of it
it's just going to be done because this
game will always evolve yeah looking
back through rares portfolio its history
of games of a pretty eclectic mix right
a couple years ago the rare collection
Illustrated that see if thief seems no
different you mentioned emergent
gameplay earlier kind of yes stories
that people kind of find themselves what
made you want to pursue that particular
kind of game when when you sat down to
brainstorm say what are we going to do
next yeah what like rare this I think
when it's 30 second year right and
there's a reason it's still around and I
think that's because it constantly
reinvents itself and it constantly looks
at where the markets going and goes and
like if they if they just made the same
game all the time like I don't think
they'd be around anymore right yes
habits change things change true so you
know at the start of this project we sat
down and we came up with this with this
idea before pirates which was about
players creating stories together that
was the original pitch document
black-and-white PowerPoint nothing
pretty but it was about we wanted to
bring a group of players together
like give them a goal but try and
encourage them to behave cooperatively
but have competition in the world but we
also wanted a theme something so and we
also wanted other players in the world
but we wanted a theme that players
understood they kind of recognized and
so when that was having to tell them
they kind of know what they're going to
go and do in the world and also the
objects in that world needed to be
something that players would recognize
and understand because again we didn't
want to have to teach players we didn't
want to have to have a wide range of
tutorials for their stuff you wanted
like you know abstract mechanics that
you have to learn right I think we've
broken that wall with firing our cannons
but that's okay it's something people
discover right but um like everything
else you you go into the game and you
know that like I'm going to be a pirate
what does that entail well I'm going to
have a ship and and the ship naturally
encourages cooperation between players
right like you can't really get anywhere
without actually cooperating but then
that comp the room for competition is
from from other players in the world and
so when we had the we had the idea we
did a bunch of one-sheets so like
basically you put an image up and a few
lines so a theme and a few images about
how this could be special how to be
unique and we now added an - about seven
and one of which was pirates and it was
just the one that stood out to us and I
think to be fair Greg males who his
creative director on the project like he
has always wanted to make a pirate game
and and he's been rare for about 31 of
those 32 years it was the banjo creative
director and over the year and so um but
so he definitely had the leaning towards
pirates and I didn't have that bias
coming into it but like it just met the
goals that would set out for ourselves
so perfectly there was just instantly so
many ways your mind could just make
sense of the pirate experience versus a
God would set out and so it was it was a
no brainer for me and so we basically
made the pitch we put together you know
the thoughts of why we wanted to do it
and chose the theme and then went and
worked on a prototype and and proved out
the gameplay for this in about probably
about five months but with a really
small team of about five engineers
couple of designers and but in unity but
basically with an ugly as sin version of
the game yeah yeah and it wasn't
connected to serve as it was all local
like it did not look like this I can
tell you that there were no artists
involved in the making of the boats all
right but
but the gameplay was there you could
sail the ship like this you could go on
quests and we were like there's
something special here yeah yeah and so
that was where it was born I'm sure you
got asked something along these lines
throughout this week but obviously
they're very different games but you
self announced Skull and Bones way
Tigger their title um I don't know yet
because I've not had a chance to play
Ram but I like I always kind of answer
this because I've been asked a few times
around there but like I like to look at
our game and what's special and I think
not just skull and bones is it and like
yeah so like we I think we had that on
our list as well when we were going
through game names we had we had a lot
but like but even since we've announced
if these back you know 2015 we had the
quantities a trailer then last year we
showed the gameplay and players playing
it and then this year showing this
experience all right I've always been
wondering is there gonna be any game
that kind of like is going after the
same thing as us of this rich shared
world with players all with different
goals with the kind of the rich feature
set and unexpected encounters within a
world and I have like an ultimately
something that I think is going to be a
massive success when it comes to people
who love to stream loved to create
videos around it I've and I've yet to
see it in any under any theme under
anything so and I've always been like is
somewhere else going to kind of go down
this route and and and I haven't and you
know so I think we've got an amazing
opportunity with this game to to really
deliver something unique and special the
players own the wallet they're already
loving it in our insider program but
that you know the broader audience is
going to love to cool
oh yeah I guess like logistically what
can we expect like going forward in
Turkey now it's like you know time
release window is what 2018 yeah early
2018 early 2018 but before that what can
we expect can we expect to get our hands
on this more before it comes out in its
full form well I think again I direct
people to the inside a program writer
like if if people want to get their
hands on this before before the kind of
the full game or the full experience is
released and certainly not the final
experience at that point we want to
continue supporting it for as long as
players are playing it sure sign up for
the insider program so like and week the
entire program has
over 200,000 people signed up now about
75,000 have got the hands on the game so
far and every time we move forward every
time we add new features throughout all
the way up to 2018 we're going to be
bringing all players in and our
commitment is that every single person
in the insider program will get a chance
to play early prior to the full release
of the game we can't say when for
everyone because right always going to
be testing new things and bringing new
stuff in but that's if you if you
excited about see if Teves
that's that's your Avenue right and I
guess my last question would be I'm
curious if the you know the reveal and
the the actual release of the Xbox 1x
impact development plans at all it
doesn't impact our plans absolutely not
like so we got the dev kits probably
five six weeks ago I'm sure they're um
and we got it up and running in about
half a day but then we were like cool it
works and because I like like any kind
of nuclear any anything you you want to
make sure that like there aren't going
to be any unexpected challenges sure and
so we got up and running they move like
a focus on e3 that's all that's all
right now and then we can come back to
to that experience a little later
quit I think I'll focus on PC because
we've already got the PC up and running
means we've already got the 4k assets
we've already got all that kind of stuff
so we're very well positioned to make to
swiftly get the Xbox one X cars up
alongside everything else cool well Joe
neat thank you so much for joining us on
our stage thank you yeah it's a chat
yeah absolutely have a good rest of the
show yeah you too guys thank you and if
you're watching from home of course you
can stay tuned again spot throughout the
rest of the week we have a lot of game
demos developer interviews coming from
e3 and we will see you around